the former U.S vice president Mike Pence
has officially entered the 2024 race for
the White House hence's bid will pit him
against his former boss Donald Trump
Alan Fisher reports from Washington D.C
we gave America A New Beginning for Life
he's in everyone knew he would be now
it's official after spending months
laying the groundwork former vice
president Mike Pence has filed the
paperwork to take on his old boss for
the Republican Presidential nomination
went against Donald Trump once before he
refused to block Joe Biden's election as
president As Trump wanted and ended up
running for his life from his supporters
because he's going to have to address
January 6th with Donald Trump presumably
right next to him and that's going to be
really interesting uh to see in terms of
how he's going to answer that how Trump
is going to respond it's going to be
really uh intriguing I don't think he
has any chance of winning Pence joins a
growing field Nikki Healey the former
U.S ambassador to the UN is in and
Senator Tim Scott of South Carolina we
knew if we worked once a trump advisor
former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie who failed in the 2016
nomination fight is expected to announce
on Tuesday North Dakota governor Doug
burgum will join this week too with Essa
Hutchinson from Arkansas who's already
declared both her names hardly known out
of their home States and early favorites
to drop out
and there's Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis expected to be Trump's biggest
challenger but most polls have him
hardly making a dent in Trump's lead
that's given others heart now they
believe they could be the person to beat
Trump I think a lot of these people
aren't running because they want to be
president honestly I think a lot of them
are running because they either want a
cabinet position or they want to be the
running mate and they refuse to attack
Donald Trump because they're afraid of
him
um and they're afraid of his base and
they want to have that support uh to
further their political Ambitions the
field is already crowded and more are
expected to join but they're all still a
long way behind Donald Trump Mike Pence
hopes he can create his own little bit
of history and become the latest vice
president to win the top job just like
the man he would ultimately have to beat
Joe Biden Alan Fisher Al Jazeera
Washington
let's not speak to as Alpha Franco who's
a Republican strategist supporter for
president Trump he's in Washington D.C
joining us from there thanks for being
with us on Al Jazeera so how unusual is
it for a former vice president to run
against the president that he served
well this is highly unusual Darlene
thank you very much for the invitation
the closest thing we've had in our
country to this is really uh 1912 but
there's not much of an analogy between
former president uh Theodore Roosevelt
and uh President Taft but that's a long
long way away so this is highly highly
unusual but of course American politics
has been highly unusual in recent years
as well yeah it has so what can we
expect then from the Pence campaign
well a couple things I thought your
report was excellent a lot of these uh
candidates are are running for the
second spot for for the cabinet of
course that's not Mr Pence's uh
possibilities he's at a very peculiar
position uh to the Republican base to
the highly uh dominated by President
Trump he seen now as disloyal uh this
reference to January 6. that does not
play well with Republican voters and
Trump supporters so he's seen as
disloyal at the same time he owns the
Trump agenda he was vice president so
other candidates such as Mr DeSantis can
distinguish themselves he just did
recently he said for example Governor
DeSantis that why didn't President Trump
accomplish a number of things regarding
the Deep State and investigations in
Mexican wall in his four years he's
attacking the Trump record
he's saying governor DeSantis I'll get
it done so he's distinguishing himself
about what he can accomplish vice
president Pence can't do that so he
can't really run against President
Trump's record that's his record and at
the same time if he runs again but it is
kind of allow me for a second I mean he
is expected to position himself as a
continuation of the Trump's agenda but
without the baggage so is that not going
to appeal to Republican voters
well that's the lane that other voters
have as well Mr DeSantis has embraced it
almost every major candidate has any
chance of winning the nomination has
embraced the Trump agenda uh almost all
of them they haven't embraced president
Trump Governor Christie for example
Embraces the agenda he just says
president Trump can't be elected but
they they don't distinguish themselves
the only ones that distinguish
themselves are people that are not
really serious contenders such as
governor hudges and of course Undeclared
candidates like Liz Cheney and and
Governor sununu so that is his you asked
the right question that is his
predicament he is continuation of trump
but disloyal to Trump so you either if
you were a trump supporter and like the
Trump agenda and you don't think
president Trump is electable he will
turn to Governor DeSantis for example
right and if you really don't like
President Trump you're not going to turn
to his vice president you would turn to
Governor Christie or others who have
attacked president Trump very directly
look what are we to read into the fact
that so far are as far as we know
according to the polls Trump is
commanding the lead and now you have a
number of candidates who are entering
the race what are we to read into that
well I read it into this into the uh
into those numbers uh and into the
candidacy I should say uh there is a
sense many of these candidates that
President Trump could implode uh we are
expecting in Washington this week later
this week an indictment president Trump
uh on a federal charges of obstruction
uh in the documents case in Mar-A-Lago
so there's even though it has helped
president Trump to date it might
continue to to help president Trump
that's unclear whether that will be
short long or long term so these
candidates are positioning themselves
with the expectation possibility that
President Trump will falter that
President Trump will become his own
victim in many sense and they will be
there to pick up the pieces that is
really what the agenda is and that's why
you've seen them gingerly uh differ with
his with his uh policy positions the
president the problem with vice
president hence is that Trump loyalists
are not going to embrace a disloyal Vice
president in the eyes are Republican
voters he might appeal to centrists
outside the Republican party or to some
Democrats but not to Republican voters
so
um his candidacy uh will either be
launched effectively in Iowa or will die
in Iowa and I will just say one
additional point I think is very
important he does appeal vice president
Trump a vice president Pence and why he
was selected by President Trump with
evangelicals Mormons religious uh
conservatives who make up the vast
majority of Iowa Republicans that's
first in our country caucus so if he
does well in Iowa and president Trump
were to falter that is his Narrow Lane
to the nomination okay thank you so much
Adolfo Franca for joining us from
Washington D.C
thank you so much